so yeah do do the impression let's see
i just get so sleepy
that's good yeah that's good pretty
creepy creepy as hell should we do
another crazy ass cold open oh of him of
him yeah and i'll play the i'll play the
other guy yeah yeah yeah let me work out
for a year yeah you want to play the hot
guy let me work out for a year yeah no
let me just call hunter and then he
that's [ __ ] up hunter i'm sorry i
couldn't not think of you the whole time
not because the guy's big cause why um
they have similar hands what i'm joking
yeah this dude killed like the actual
dude killed um and then the actor killed
this role yeah so this is a true story
yeah
damn oh yeah how far are you into this
only a couple episodes you
i watched the first three i think and
then i mean i haven't had a chance i'm
so glad you gave me this movie ticket
we're gonna have so much fun
i wish i could do the other guy oh yeah
you wanna do the other guy
yeah so
you would do what to these girls
i feel the same
[Laughter]
wait what was his name again
him no the yeah the hot dude i don't
know archer no [ __ ]
jimmy jimmy yeah and then um larry
hall's in the other room like
good night jimmy
[Music]
good night
nice that's good somebody's
signed this man yeah i know what you
mean about apple tv dialogue yeah right
if they were bad actors that script
would be horrible horrendous but it's
just tolerable and also like every time
like in whatever episode i just watched
episode three or something like that
when the guard
asks him for a loan yeah and he goes
into a cell and they're like screaming
at each other and it's right beside the
cell yeah it's like and then he walks
out and walks into their cell and the
guy just didn't hear a single word come
on man show does a really good job of
creating tension yeah you know where a
lot of that tension is created those
random medium shots of all the
characters just doing nothing someone's
talking they just cut to one of them
going like
yeah it's like a video game cut scene
the whole thing it it feels really
cool yeah it's a good show
yeah it's it's definitely just overdone
a little bit
yeah it almost like it's trying to be
true detective you know you know uh
fbi agent laura mccauley isaiah would
fall hard as [ __ ] for her yeah that's
some alpha female alpha female
alpha fee vibes right there yeah dude
when she goes i'm your girlfriend
grab my ass
kiss me yeah just make you look
realistic she was starting yeah yeah
yeah
did such a chat
jimbo yeah dude the scene such as like a
staten island chad i did appreciate
though the realism in the medium stroke
that he had he wouldn't give him like
long like back blowing strokes and all
his sex scenes yeah they were just
averaged yeah yeah just using all six
[Laughter]
just giving everything he's got in there
that felt like a more realistic sex
scene and she said they're like yeah fun
this is awesome
yeah that's what sex is like
you know the difference i'm just saying
i've had it so yeah
yeah yeah we believe you yeah yeah for
sure
it is a good show you know what [ __ ]
movie rules elvis
no hold on you're marketing to that [ __ ]
for like two years you're not allowed to
you're not about to let me walk solo
on analyzing the stroke of the main
character from blackbird you are going
down on this [ __ ] airplane with me
you you will you will validate me right
now okay so good what was your point i
just appreciate that he wasn't giving
movie stroke yeah yeah yeah it wasn't
even more realistic realistic just like
kind of yeah yeah movie stroke it
sometimes feels like it starts from like
the other side of the room yeah you know
yeah
like their ankles go in the air every
stroke yeah and the girl's like enjoying
it
way too much yeah that's movie stroke
yeah okay no it was
it was realism stroke yeah right is that
do you like is it is it good or are you
uncomfortable yeah
yeah i'm sorry my thigh is cramping oh
sorry okay can we just can we just sorry
can we just just move over sorry i don't
mean to no no it's really good it's just
you know it's it's my thigh cramping
oh
real stroke
dude that was so corny when he made the
first of all did they tell him to walk
like that and lift his
eyebrow in the air everything like with
everything he did yeah like after he got
done having sex with that woman when the
the morning of the raid he like goes to
make his shake and he's like
yeah
it blends the [ __ ] up turns back to her
looks at her naked ass he's like
turns back around yeah yeah yeah
and then
they raid the place what's your post
[ __ ] routine because that's mine my post
[ __ ] routine nice that was fun i'm gonna
go make a smoothie yeah i'm gonna make a
green shake just not even offer one for
her yeah to her
talking to her while she's asleep you
know you're right that's exactly what i
do yeah no i usually just like
exactly
and she's like hey hey
you need to pee um
[Laughter]
reminding you
yeah
then i just fall asleep on the toilet
yeah you know i don't want you getting a
uti oh yeah [ __ ] good idea
that's romance
that is romance right there and then for
the beginning of the piss
it like shoots out yeah you know the
scene the scene in different directions
no dude for the first beginning part of
the piss just a little bit like creeps
through the the seat and the top of the
bowl just for a second
i was just like uncoiling just like it's
then it falls into the bowl and just
that's real stroke that's that's real
stroke they call this movie stroke yeah
god appreciate i appreciate they
balanced him out a little bit yeah
everything else this guy does is perfect
yeah
but he's got he's got realism stroke you
know that was that was encouraging i was
smart on behalf of apple tv no when he
got arrested
and they tackle him and they
get the overhead shot of his shake going
in the air and then when they arrest him
they're like mushing his face into the
[ __ ] i was like come on why it just felt
so like movie just too perfect yeah yeah
like they roll them over to arrest them
it's like
yeah yeah exactly it's hollywood
dialogue right there and then then alpha
phi walks in what's this jimbo that's an
ak-47
yeah it's still a good show yeah that's
good so wait what episode are you at i
think i think i just finished three just
don't just you wait have you finished it
oh yeah okay it gets i'm gonna finish it
[ __ ] dementor but i have to finish
elvis first because i watched half of it
no you did
bro my flight was at 6 00 a.m this
morning
i couldn't we you know here you come in
here raving about a movie it's a good
movie
i cannot wait to get home and watch the
rest you don't even need to talk about
it yet like why it's a good movie
no no no no movie is good like this no i
didn't watch it on the plane i watched
it last night oh okay all right all
right
i had to get up at 3 30 i see i see so i
was like okay this thing's two and a
half hours it's an hour into it i'm
really enjoying it let's put it on pause
go to bed try and get like five hours of
sleep wake up hit the flight come
straight here
still in my [ __ ] plane clothes which
is a sacrifice yeah because you know the
g7 doesn't have a shower we're not
watching the whole movie no no no no no
but it's this it's that your your movie
consumption it's like it's like a fridge
it's like all leftovers in there i think
that's the frustrating part right is
that we know that you just you have a
half can of elvis you just threw in the
fridge
and it's sitting there
how long are those good for
like like a couple weeks so there you go
blackbird in there and there's and
there's elvis right now yeah i'm sure we
got other old [ __ ] in there